I mean all of these really are just
spur-of-the-moment
I was on the internet and I was like you
know this is tight let's go Justin
Bieber was the guy that inspired me to
get tattoos because who's in the studio
and as I came in is that hurt because
that's when I just had first man and he
was like no well my first tattoo was
this Playboy bunny right here I was
playing basketball with Justin Bieber
and while it was healing and he just
messed up the whole thing but it still
looks kind of tight it looks like magma
Justin did apologize but he's gonna have
to buy me a new one we were in the club
and he was talking about getting hand
tats he asked me if he should do it I
told him yeah I'll tell him it's very
rock star life you know I mean it's all
like my my favorite artist you know that
have passed and I'm about to do all ten
I'm gonna get Jim Morrison and George
Harrison right next to John and
everything without these guys I wouldn't
be making music right now
I just got this like two days ago
it's a snake with a wrapped around an
f-16 this is a Gadsden snake you know
don't tread on me it has to do with the
Second Amendment kind of but you know
like you know the right to bear arms and
then I got this little cartier love
bangle logo right here and that was the
most painful one that I've ever gotten
in my life afterwards we just felt crazy
it felt like it was tattoo of my soul my
tattoo my tattoo pad is about to go
crazy I'm just starting my guys coming
in from Dallas is just about the tooth
all of this on and he's just gonna fill
everything in and go on here everywhere
I might get a sword on my face like a
claymore rock and roll